[Applause]
are there any questions I know it's kind
of a weird way to open a conference
isn't it normally we do questions at the
end but this year the lovely people in
NDC have asked me to do the opening
keynote and I thought it would be fun if
we mixed everything up and we talked
about the questions right at the
beginning but first welcome everyone to
NDC Oslo 2017 it's a great pleasure to
be here it's great to see so many of you
here I realize its first thing in the
morning
there were geek beers last night those
people just flown in as jet lag there's
people who stayed up until it got dark
and they're never going to make that
mistake in Norway and summer again so
welcome thank you for being here it's
great to see you all I hope that by the
end of this talk you're going to feel
inspired you're going to feel wired
you're going to be ready for three days
of the best speakers the best sessions
the best technical content you'll find
anywhere in the world does that sound
okay to you awesome
ok so audience interaction is going to
work that's good I thought I might have
to get the Irish and Australians to come
down the front because they don't mind
shouting so much so are there any
questions you know like I said it's a
funny way to be opening a tech
conference but we're here at MDC to talk
about innovation we're here to talk
about invention we're here to talk about
how we can build better systems better
solutions better teams and in order to
do that in order to aspire to the future
I think we need to understand how we got
here and the history of invention and
innovation is all about questions you
know human beings are curious creatures
once upon a time something crawled out
of a swamp and it looked around and went
hey this is nice I wonder if there's
anything out here that I can eat we look
to the far horizon we look out across
the ocean and we think hey you know do
you reckon we can that is there
something over there can we go there is
there stuff there we can go and look at
we look up at the stars and we think can
we go there is there anything up there
is there anyone looking down at us are
we alone in the universe
us everything that we know everything
that we learn is driven by curiosity by
questions
the poet Rudyard Kipling had this lovely
verse he wrote once I keep six honest
serving men who taught me all I knew
their names are what and why and when
and how and where and who and when we
can't find answers to our questions
that's when we get really inventive
because we build things you know we are
creative we invent things to help us
answer these questions we invented
arithmetic we invented language we
invented libraries and telescopes and
algorithms and sailing ships all of
which started out with somebody asking a
question and so today we're going to
talk about questions we're going to
start with some of the simplest
questions of all and I told you we're
going to do things backwards so not only
we do in questions at the beginning but
I'm going to ask them and you're going
to answer them so what I do I ask you a
question I'll count three two one I want
all you to shout the answer so you up
for that you shout yes three two one
awesome okay nice simple one to start
off with two plus two equals three to
hang on hang on hang on okay so I
realize that a child of five can answer
this question but most of us here are
professional software developers so it's
a little bit more complicated so just to
clarify the requirements these are
ordinary numbers two plus two this is
regular arithmetic I would like you to
use base 10 and I would like you please
to shout your answers in English okay
so now that we've cleared up their
requirements two plus two equals three
two one four excellent let's do another
one five times eight equals three two
one fantastic these kinds of questions
these you know kinds of operations are
some of the first simplest questions we
ever learn they were some of the first
things that humankind developed some of
the first arithmetic techniques were
developed by the ancient Greeks there
are some of the first things that we
learn in school and you know for
centuries we've done these calculations
by hand they were actually people
employed just to do these kinds of
calculations
we had a word for these people you know
we called them computers and one of the
first computers of all was this guy
Blaise Pascal Pascal was a French
mathematician who at the age of 19 was
working in his father's Tax Office in
France Pascal was a genius he had an
astonishing talent for mathematics and
science and I would argue he was one of
the first hackers because when someone
gave him a stack of these you know forms
to add up to calculate who and what tax
he kind of looked anyone you know I
could build something to do that and he
created this nineteen years old
Pascal created the first ever mechanical
calculating machine became later known
as the Pascaline it didn't do anything
we couldn't do by hand but what it could
do was it could crunch numbers fast and
accurately and that ability the ability
to you know do arithmetic quickly and
get reliable results every time unlocked
centuries of innovation in all sorts of
areas finance commerce mathematics
science navigation warfare and over the
next 300 years these mechanical
calculators proved really really
effective at dealing with these kinds of
questions you know fairly simple they
didn't do anything we couldn't do by
hand what they could do was they could
answer these questions quickly and
accurately and as you know as late as
the 1970s mechanical calculators were
still being manufactured and sold and
used in all sorts of financial
applications but mechanical calculating
machines had a fundamental limitation
because they were mechanical they were
constrained by the limits of what it was
possible to build Charles Babbage the
great English mathematician and
philosopher invented the clicker
he invented something called the
difference engine which was a mechanical
machine for generating logarithmic
tables and now Babbage invented the
difference engine Babbage invented
another really important innovation in
IT because he went to the British
government and said I got this great
idea for a machine and they offered to
pay for it so Babbage invented the
government IT project you know how you
can tell it was a government IT project
it blew its budget by a factor of 10 it
over an by a decade it did not deliver a
working prototype and it was eventually
abandoned it wasn't that his designs
didn't work in the 1990s the Science
Museum in London actually constructed
Babbage's Difference Engine and it
worked it worked flawlessly it's just
that in the 19th century it was
impossible to produce the gears and the
components that were required to make
this machine work so after you know we
have the Pascaline we had the difference
engine but for hundreds of years people
were dependent on manually creating
tables of logarithms tables of
algorithms tables of numbers for use in
mathematics the first half of the 20th
century was defined by two great world
wars and during those wars governments
would invest anything any amount of time
money resources in anything that might
give them a tactical advantage and these
kinds of calculations artillery
trajectory firing ranges these kinds of
things with no exception this is another
government elite IT project this is
ENIAC the electronic numerical
integrator and calculator it was created
by the United States government during
World War two being a government IT
project by the time it finally shipped
in 1946 the war was over missed its
deadline but you know the potential of
these kinds of machines you know any a
cook as much power as a small town to
run it was huge it was hot it ran on
vacuum tube technology but it was still
a thousand times faster than anything we
had ever had before it could do in 30
seconds what it took human
mathematicians something like 20 hours
to calculate the potential of this kind
of technology was astonishing
in the mid-1950s these things vacuum
tubes were replaced by these things
transistors it made computers much
cheaper to run it made them cooler and
make them more reliable in the 60s they
invented the integrated circuit a way of
putting a lot of these transistors on
one tiny little silicon wafer which made
them massively cheaper to produce some
of you've probably heard of Moore's Law
Gordon Moore who was one of the founders
of Intel made this observation that the
available computing power will double
every 18 months Moore made this
observation in 1965 and for single chips
you know single core processors it
pretty much helped true until about 2005
2006 so we're talking you know 40 nearly
50 years of constant doubling Hertz 2
kilohertz 2 megahertz to gigahertz
remember those you're going a thousand
times faster than you were previously
this is you know astonishing less than
half a century and the reason Moore's
law finally stopped being true is we
made chip so small that the electrons
stop behaving like electrons and start
doing weird quantum stuff less than half
a century to go from vacuum tubes to
weird quantum stuff you know that I
think is absolutely fantastic and it
seems sometimes like the potential of
these machines is limitless but let's
throw some more questions at you here we
go nice easy one three times seven
equals three to 121 okay five times 11
equals 65 okay let's flip it around a
little bit so 65 divides by two numbers
a and B we're going to count three two
one and then I want you to shout them
both out smallest one first so three two
one five thirteen okay now you're paying
attention
a times B equals 773 trillion 978
billion primary five million six hundred
sixty-four thousand eight hundred and
eighty-one what are ANB three two one
[Laughter]
the answer is of course I'm not going to
bother reading it now the point about
this is if you were using a you know
ordinary pocket calculator you could
check a number every 10 minutes seconds
or so it would take you something like
five years to work at what two factors
divided into this number even if you
wrote a computer program that could test
thousands of numbers every second you'd
still be looking at a runtime on the
order of weeks to solve this relatively
simple problem it's simple but it's
expensive to solve and there are no
shortcuts now you know even using Blaise
Pascal's mechanical computer you could
multiply these two numbers together to
get that result in a couple of minutes
but reversing it is so expensive as to
be practically impossible and you might
think that's a problem and for some
people it is a problem but actually a
lot of stuff that we do depends on it
this is what we call a trapdoor function
it is a question that is very easy to
solve in one direction like falling
through a trapdoor and very very
difficult to do in the other direction
like climbing back out again every time
you send a whatsapp message every time
you log into Gmail every time you use
your credit card on the internet you are
relying on these kinds of trapdoor
functions to make sure nobody can
intercept your details no one can read
your messages no one can hack into your
email now as I said cracking these
questions is to all intents and purposes
well impossible we assume that no one
can break them but we have to ask the
question you know what if they could
modern graphics cards you know the kind
of chips we buy to run battlefield and
fire cry and that kind of thing are now
approaching levels that 10 years ago you
needed a supercomputer people use these
for Bitcoin mining people use these for
doing crypto analysis people use these
to try and break encryption systems and
we're kind of at a point now if you're
using relatively weak encryption
somebody you know small company or a
very wealthy individual they could get
they could buy a rack of nvidia gpus and
probably crack your encryption within
you know not instantly but if they
focused on you a couple of months if
they had enough no traffic enough
activity and I've information
for them to do a decent crypto analysis
they could probably break it in a matter
of months now that's easy because all we
need to do to make it go from three
months for six months is to add one bit
to the size of the key we're using if
you're using a 64-bit key and someone
can crack you in a year use a 65 bit key
it'll take them two years 66 bit year
it'll take them four years
128-bit key straight back near a game
over you're secure again question is
what happens if we find a fundamentally
different way of approaching these kind
of functions now this is already sort of
happening with something called quantum
computing this is a one-hour keynote I
am NOT going to explain how quantum
computing works in a keynote it would
take several days what I'm going to do
is to invoke arthur c clarke third law
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic and I'm
going to say quantum computers are
sufficiently advanced and therefore
they're magic now these things exist
this is from Wired magazine you can
actually go and buy a d-wave quantum
computer now and I think the biggest
prime product that any quantum computer
has factorized yet is 15 but it did it
using a profoundly different algorithm a
fundamentally different approach to
arithmetic to anything that we've ever
seen before now you know these things
exist they are going to get better the
question is how quickly and what are we
going to do when everyone has one of
these okay so far we've talked about
arithmetic we've talked about what we
call a priori questions questions where
everything you need to know to answer
the question is in the question things
that you can work out for yourself now
we are going to talk about something
called a posterior equestions these are
questions where you need to look
something up and again we're going to
start by me asking you some questions
and you shouting out the answers so
first question what is the capital of
Norway
three-two-one Oslo very good question -
what is the capital of Sweden
three-two-one Stockholm correct you
weren't born knowing these things and
there's no way you could work them out
from first principles these are things
that we have learned these are things
you know over the course of all of our
lives we
have geography lessons in school we read
articles we read things in the newspaper
we read books and we reinforce these
facts to the point where if someone
stands up on a stage like this and says
hey what's the capital of Sweden you can
all shout out the answer now we're
getting here into a category of
questions and a field of information
technology called information retrieval
early computers you know
Blaze's Pascaline the early ENIAC
computers right up til the 1980s they
had kind of just about enough storage to
deal with what they were doing they had
enough storage to carry digits in a
calculation they had enough storage to
track the program they were running the
idea of using them as a place to store
information
you know you didn't put information on
the computer unless the computer needed
it to be there because storage was so
expensive it was expensive in terms of
you know finance it cost a lot to
manufacture it was expensive to access
because it was slow it was expensive to
manage and you know computers were fun
for doing spreadsheets and playing games
but if you actually want to look
anything up you had to use one of these
and so for the junior developers in the
audience this is a book a book is a
sequential document database implemented
in hardware and they don't have Wi-Fi
the battery life on them is phenomenal
you know so books are wonderful I love
books all the time except what I'm
moving house and you have that one box
they hate you just can't pick up because
it's full of books but books had their
limitations you know they're heavy they
have limits on what they can store and
they are sequential access you need to
know where to find that than you want so
let's take a look at this now some of
you have perhaps never seen this before
some of you probably used it to do your
homework when you were at school there
might even be one or two people here who
actually worked on authoring these
things back in the day there was a
little period in the 1990s when CD ROMs
were the new hotness 650 megabytes and
multimedia and all kinds of stuff that
you know today we take for granted
people had never seen this before you
know there were people who were like is
that computer playing a video and it was
literally like they thought it was a
trick they thought someone you know
plugged in a VCR another piece of
obsolete technology junior developers
won't have heard of
and many of these systems use something
called hypermedia to allow you to
navigate from one article the next so
you could go to an article about
Scandinavia and click Sweden and Sweden
you could click Stockholm and you could
click and you could get a photograph and
then someone he had a bright idea this
guy Tim Sir Tim berners-lee web
developer and Tim's idea was what is the
articles you were linking together
didn't all have to be on the same cd-rom
what if they didn't even have to be on
the same computer what if we could come
up with a way that we could have some
standard software that was a could
navigate between all these articles and
the articles could be stored wherever we
wanted them and we'd use networks to get
to them until it invented three things
he invented HTML which was a standard
format for putting links and anchors and
formatting into plain text files he
invented HTTP which was a network
protocol that would allow you to go to
any computer and say hey can I have a
copy of that article you're hosting
there and he invented URLs Resource
locators a way of addressing information
that was stored somewhere on the
Internet
this idea that you know anybody in the
world could put information online that
anyone could go and access for free was
you know it was a game changer and it
took some getting used to some of us got
used to it really really quickly so you
know day one teach yourself HTML in 24
hours day to get a business card with
the word webmaster written on it I
haven't had a proper job since you know
it but for a lot of people a lot of
industries this was a massive shock in
the 90s you could buy this this was a
book a printed book that you looked up
the thing you were interested in and it
would tell you what websites you could
go to to read about it now you know I
want you to imagine the meeting there's
a bunch of executives and a book
publishing company sat around and
somebody comes in and goes you know I
can tell you something they've invented
this thing which means anyone in the
world can publish information on the
internet for free and anyone in the
world can read it for free and they sit
around they think wow yeah we could
write a book about that you know it's
like a blacksmith watching the first
motor car and thinking yeah you could
deliver lots of austria's in one of
those I got to get one of those you know
this
this unwillingness they literally could
not come up with a response lots of
companies lots of organizations actually
you know burned out and died trying to
respond to the way that the internet had
changed the world wide web changed the
face of publishing it wasn't long before
we realized that books were not really a
good way to navigate the web because you
can make a webpage in two minutes and it
takes six months to print a book and so
we invented the search engine the very
thing that made the web so beautiful and
so complex this idea of hyper media
would also be the thing which allowed us
to tame it and navigate it we created
spiders spots software applications that
would jump from one web page to the next
to the next to the next to the next
keeping track of everything they did
building these vast databases that
mapped this you know ever-changing
digital world we were creating and it
wasn't long before internet search
engines just if you had a question you
just went and looked it up AltaVista
like Ross HotBot Ask Jeeves Yahoo all of
these early search engines would answer
all these questions what's the capital
of Italy where can I buy a new pair of
shoes when was mozart bought all these
kinds of questions you just you know
google has now become a verb i'll just
google it means you know go and look it
up online google it with Bing if you
really want you know but you know these
search engines had a fundamental
limitation because they didn't actually
answer questions all they did was look
look for keywords and math patents so a
search and wouldn't find this article
and Wikipedia and it would go okay what
keywords here interesting Helsinki is
the capital of Finland and it would
pretend it was answering the question
and it looked a lot of the time like it
was but there was a drawback to this
approach
now when respectable journals write
articles about the moon-landing they
very seldom use the word fake or the
word conspiracy and when respectable
journals write about fake things and
conspiracies they generally don't
mention the moon landings so if you go
onto a pattern matching search engine
and type in moon landing fake conspiracy
what it will find for you is lots and
lots of articles written by people who
think that these words should go
together which I think we now is it fake
news or alternative facts oh I'm never
entirely sure
but you know this this actually became a
problem for a long time mainstream
science no one ever published any papers
on a relationship between vaccinations
and autism because there wasn't one and
then people started putting up articles
saying vaccines autism and you know
scared parents would go on the internet
to look for information and what they'd
find was this massive load of article
saying there's a relationship and they
wouldn't find anything in the other camp
and so now scientific journals are
actually publishing articles that say is
there a relationship between vaccines
and autism no you know just to address
the balance just to try and compensate
for the way that these search engines
and this pattern matching behavior is
actually changing the way the world
works the way people interact but you
know even if we're just sticking to
valid legitimate questions the way we
phrase questions can actually expose an
enormous amount about how we're thinking
about the world so we've had a bunch of
questions I'm going to ask you another
one
what is the capital of South Africa
three two one hands up who shouted
Pretoria hands up who shouted Cape Town
hands up who shouted Johannesburg anyone
for bloom Fontaine South Africa does not
have a capital when the new constitution
for the Republican South Africa was
drafted in 1994 after the end of
apartheid they decided no one city was
going to be the capital they distributed
the administrative functions of their
country in four different places Cape
Town is where Parliament sits Pretoria
is where the president lives in the
cabinet sits the Supreme Court is in
bloom Fontaine the Constitutional Court
is in Johannesburg so when you say
what's the capital of South Africa what
you're you know by asking that question
you're saying I have a mental model of
geography in which every country has
exactly one capital city where all the
important stuff happens now you know
sometimes it doesn't matter sometimes
it's just you score points in a pub quiz
for knowing that South Africa has three
constitutional cities but none of them
are actually capitals but sometimes it
can be a lot more serious than that
here's a standard set of questions that
you probably get asked to fill out when
you you know book a flight open a bank
account apply for a credit card you know
try and buy a house all kinds of things
this assumes that every single person
who might ever want to get on an
aeroplane has a first name and the last
name and they have a date of birth and
they have a sex which is either male or
female there are lots of people for whom
this isn't true there are people who do
not have a first name they just unknown
by a single last name there are lots of
people who do not may have a date of
birth but they don't know what it is in
Afghanistan there is this thing that
everyone on Afghanistan celebrates their
birthday on the 1st of January because
throughout the 1970s and 1980s the state
of infrastructure there with the Civil
War meant birth didn't get recorded
people don't know when they were born
so when they started having to fill out
forms they just put you know 1-1 1978
which you know sounds harmless enough
and then someone comes in and goes well
we're going to do medical checkups for
everybody and to get them to distribute
evenly throughout the year to balance
the load on our health service we'll get
people to come in a week after their
birthday which doesn't work in
Afghanistan because everyone gets a
letter on the 1st of January saying time
to come in for your checkup you know as
developers we can change this more and
more you know processing and booking
processes bureaucracy the stuff is
moving online and we're the people who
get asked to build and we're the people
who can turn around and go you know why
are we doing this you know go to go to
your boss go to your customer do you
really need to know whether someone's
male or female you know whatever they
why does that matter you're sitting them
on an airplane and flying them somewhere
does it matter because what you get
you're on it with a world where your
users are unhappy your database is full
of crap because people are having to lie
and fill in inaccurate things to get
through these and I'd rather live in a
world where the database is accurate the
users are happy and the form validation
doesn't suck you know I think that's
pretty reasonable ok so another question
what's the capital of Norway
three-two-one no no the capital of
Norway as of when I looked yesterday is
8 trillion 76 billion yada yada yada
Norwegian kroner Norway has a fund that
insulates the Norwegian economy against
fluctuations in international oil prices
so if you ask what are the capital of
Norway in terms of capital assets this
is how much they've got and actually
this number is
going up at quite an alarming rate okay
let's ask you another question
what's the capital of Norway you said n
is the correct answer the capital of
Norway is n the correct answers to our
questions often depends on context
capital can mean a lot of different
things you know we have capital cities
we have capital funds we have capital
punishment we have capital letters and
if you don't understand the context of
the question that's being asked it can
be very difficult to know what answer
you should give one of the things that I
love doing is cryptic crossword puzzles
because what they do is they play with
the way you assume context about
questions here's an example of a clue
from a cryptic crossword US capital
after Norwegian capital event
well the Norwegian capital is obviously
n as we already know and the US capital
is DC they go if this thing makes you go
that's cheating then you're probably not
the right kind of person to be working
on natural language processing because
natural language you know those kinds of
algorithms they have to try and solve
these things without any context they
don't have the cues that we use in
conversation they don't have tone of
voice
they don't have body language they don't
know where you're having the
conversation have you ever had a
conversation with someone where you turn
to them and go hey did you remember to
do the thing with the lady at the place
and they go yeah and you know what they
mean and there's no information in that
sentence but both of you know exactly
what it is they're talking about context
can be vitally important and sometimes
the context itself can be the most
important question of all so software
developer is out one day walking the
countryside a group of people come
overhead in a hot-air balloon and they
come down low and one of them shouts
over the side Hey
and she shouts up hello and they shout
down kids tell me where I am and she
shuts up yeah you're in a balloon and he
says you're an engineer aren't you and
she says how did you know he says you've
told me something that's completely
accurate and totally useless and she
shuts back you're a project manager
aren't you
and he says how did you know and she
says you don't know where you are you
don't know where you're going you've
started something you have no idea how
to finish and somehow you believe that
your problem is my responsibility
where am I is a far more interesting
question than it might look because you
know as we've seen we're curious
creatures we don't like to sit still
we have wonder lust we climb mountains
and we walk over deserts and we build
ships and sail em out to sea and when
you get out on the open ocean working
out where you are can be really really
difficult we determine position on the
surface of the earth using two things
latitude and longitude latitude tells
you how far north or south of the
equator you've gone longitude tells you
how far east or west of the Greenwich
Meridian you have gone determining
latitude is easy you wait till it gets
dark you look for the pole star Polaris
if Polaris is directly overhead you are
at the North Pole
if Polaris is on the horizon you're on
the equator you can calculate everything
between this the only place this is a
problem is in Scandinavia and somewhere
it doesn't get dark so you can't see the
pole star so to determine a latitude in
Scandinavia what you do is you go into a
bar and you order a beer if it costs
more than your phone you're in Denmark
cost more than your car you're in Sweden
and if it costs more than your house
you're in Norway determining longitude
is much more difficult and I said it's
actually quite easy what you do is you
get a greenwich here in the city of
london and you wait until the Sun is
directly overhead and you set your
wristwatch to Newton then you get in
your chip and you write the Tradewinds
right across the Atlantic and you know
after a couple of days when you're
thousands of miles out you want to know
how how far across you are how far
you've traveled so you wait until the
Sun is directly overhead and you look at
your watch and your watch says 8:00 a.m.
Suns I've heard so you're like well if
it's noon here and it's still eight
o'clock in London I'm four hours west of
the Greenwich Meridian you know easy
except what normally happens is they get
out to see look at that wristwatch and
go on now count it's 16 22 and I don't
have a wristwatch hasn't been invented
yet if you were lucky what you could do
is just go north get the latitude you
want turn left and hit America before
you sank or ran out of food if you are
unlucky you'd get lost your ship would
run aground
people would die this is exactly what
happened to the British naval fleet in
1707 vice-admiral's fleet ran aground on
the Isles of Scilly hundreds of people
were killed four ships were lost
the British government determined
something called the Admiralty prize the
longitude Act basically is over 2
million pounds worth in today's money
prize for the first person to work out a
way of determining longitude this guy
John Harrison eventually wanted he spent
most of his life working on it and he
produced this the Harrison sea
chronometer an absolute marvel of
engineering this is a mechanical clock
that runs on pendulums that will keep
accurate time to within one second in
six months even if it is on a ship at
sea that is rocking and rising and
falling with the swell it's an absolute
masterpiece this is on display in the
Royal Naval Museum and Greenwich in
London and it's a fantastic piece of
piece of engineering because these days
you only know where you are you don't
need to check your Harrison sea
chronometer at noon what you do is you
use GPS you say where are we and it says
you are bang yeah Oslo Spektrum in
Norway which sounds you know pretty
simple it's GPS is based on a technical
trilateration if you have three fixed
points and you know your distance from
them you can work out where you are and
there was a problem because the
mathematics is all well and good but
when you're a couple of hundred thousand
miles out to sea there are no fixed
points and so if someone had this
brilliant idea they said I've got a
great idea lads why don't we put the
fixed points in outer space where
everyone can see them GPS uses 33
satellites in orbit around the earth
height around 20,000 kilometres to put
those satellites there we invented
liquid-fueled rockets that we literally
tested by throwing bombs into them while
they were running just to make sure they
were going to be able to cope with what
we were asking them to do these are the
Rockets that took us to the moon these
are the Rockets that launched the
International Space Station same rockets
that put Voyager and pioneer on their
journey beyond the edges of our solar
system so we had a way of parking these
fixed points in orbit next thing we have
to do is work out a way of determining
distance from them and someone had the
bright idea well why don't we put clocks
on the satellites and what the satellite
will do is it'll broadcast
no that says the time here is now and
then when you receive that signal you
know what time it is where you are and
you can see how far away the satellite
is so we built these atomic clocks
accurate to one millisecond in a decade
and if they start to drift GPS
satellites carry four of them so if one
of them goes wrong it can use the other
three to compensate by the way did I
mention 20,000 kilometres above the
earth physics actually works differently
because the gravity well Einstein's
equations determined the time flows
differently where gravity is weaker so
as you move away from the earth time
itself actually ticks at a different
speed you know how do you simulate that
in your staging environment if you're
writing software that's going to run
somewhere where the laws of physics tick
at a different speed how you even cope
with that but we did you know we built
these astonishingly accurate clocks we
launched them into orbit we built this
artificial constellation if your GPS
signal is out by one millisecond your
position will be out by 200 miles that
is how precise this system needs to be
and you know what we use to tap into
this network you know radio and cross
copes massive specialist antenna now we
use this you get your phone out your
pocket and you have Google Maps and it
tells you where you are by talking to
outer space where we have atomic clocks
running outside of gravity well I think
that's phenomenal I was in Israel last
month in Tel Aviv and I was going to
meet some people for a drink and I took
a bus and I can't read Hebrew
I've never been to Tel Aviv before I
can't read the alphabet I didn't speak
the language but it's fine I had GPS you
know I sat on this bus and I watched
this little blue dot make its way around
that the Google Maps thing and you know
it was magic it's such a wonderful
experience being able to ride a bus in a
foreign city and they are not going to
get lost what actually happened is that
someone ping me on Twitter and I switch
to Twitter and I missed my stop because
I was playing on my phone but you know
you can't win them all
most amazing thing about GPS is it is
free like actually genuinely totally
hundred percent free no license no terms
and conditions no encryption keys no
nothing the entire planet is just bathed
in these radio waves and anyone who can
build a receiver can tap into this thing
and determine their position anytime and
you know that we have to thank for this
this is the thing that really blows my
mind it's not some you know billionaire
philanthropist it's not the United
Nations is not CERN the United States
Air Force who put this thing up in orbit
for military use and then realized maybe
we should just let everyone tap into
this let everyone use it so next time
you're out in the rain and you know
you'll get your phone and your pocket
and hail and uber to get to your
location remember to say thank you to
the ancient Greeks of trilateration to
the British Admiralty for incentivizing
it to Einstein to quantum computing to
atomic clocks and don't forget to say
thank you to Uncle Sam now this is just
the context we can get from GPS when you
combine that kind of geolocation
information your phone's camera your
phone's microphone with the gigabytes of
data that all of us are sharing
consciously or unconsciously on social
media on Twitter on Facebook Instagram
all these platforms you know we get to a
point where technology could actually
answer some really really astonishing
questions hey Siri Siri hey Siri Alexa
where's my phone Dylan when you got home
last night you put your phone in the
refrigerator I'm not sure why you did
this okay thanks Alexa hey ah hey Cherie
what happened last night
hello Dylan your calendar says you were
having a quiet dinner with some friends
okay
I know my calendar says I was having a
quiet dinner what sighs Siri what
actually happened last night well Dylan
at 23:07 you checked into the Dubliner
pub with rich campbell and Rob Connery
at 2:15 a.m. somebody posted a video on
Instagram of you doing Bon Jovi karaoke
bammy at 3:26 a.m. you took a taxi to
the Radisson Hotel your GPS trace
and shows that you walked around the
hotel twice and had a little sit down
before you finally returned to your room
okay well that explains the headache all
right ah sorry what am i doing today
you're doing the opening keynote of NTC
Oslo at 9:00 a.m. you're talking to SAS
from channel 9 at 11:20 and giving a
talk about happy code in room 7 at 1740
you also need to buy a birthday present
for your mother my mother's bust I
completely forgot um Siri what should I
buy my mum's on her birthday well Dylan
I've analyzed her browsing activity and
noticed that she keeps searching for
Canon DSLR cameras sometimes she will
add one to her shopping cart and then
open her online banking in a new tab and
end up not ordering it I think a Canon
EOS 1100 D would make a wonderful gift
Suri
are you stalking my mum Dylan you're the
one asking a computerised assistant what
to buy your mother for her birthday
let's not pretend I'm the one with the
problem here Thank You Suri sorry whilst
we're here
do you have anything you'd like to say
to the audience of NDC Oslo 2017 yes
Dylan I do please tell them I hope they
all have a really fantastic time and
that Android is for losers Thank You
Suri Thank You Dylan goodbye didn't but
you know what these kinds of questions
that temporary they're ephemeral they
matter you know where I'm I can be life
and death or it can be do I walk or take
a bus but once you know where you are
the question doesn't really matter
anymore you may get an answer to it you
make a decision you get on with your
life not all questions yield so easily
not all answers are so straightforward
being human can be a profoundly
frightening experience you know where
there's a bright light you get slapped
the next thing you know someone's trying
to teach you long division and you're
worrying about who you should invite to
your birthday party as we grew up you
know we change we change from babies to
children to teenagers to adults bodies
change minds change
you know we're not just curious
creatures we're social creatures as well
one of the most frightening things that
you can go through as a human being is
you know that fear of not fitting in the
fear that you know something is wrong
you know what's happening to me is this
normal why do I feel like I don't fit in
why am i different now
generations of kids grew up with no one
who can answer these questions for them
they couldn't talk to anyone they
couldn't talk to their parents they
couldn't talk to their teachers they
couldn't look it up in a library
couldn't talk to their friends one of
the most amazing things I think about
the information age is these are
important questions you know questions
about health about sexuality about
gender identity questions that if you
don't get answers to them alienation
anxiety you know depression even suicide
we live in an age now where for the
price of it you know cheap smartphone or
a laptop kids can ask these questions
and connect with people all over the
world could get back to them straight
away yeah it's fine don't worry that's
normal it's okay you're just the most
interesting kid in your high school
class and we think that's awesome you
know I think this is amazing we built a
computer network that turned into a
support network and that support network
has turned into a movement and that
movement ends up changing things
changing ideas changing minds changing
the world every time a company realized
that male or female just isn't the right
question for some of their customers
every time you know a social media
campaign takes on one of these big
multinationals and wins every time a
country of government look at these
archaic outdated laws and go you know
what we should roll out that we should
abolish that that doesn't make any sense
that's a step towards the world where
these assumptions and prejudices you
know they've lost their currency people
have to think instead of just falling
back on social conditioning and you know
the more these corrupt multinationals
try and control information the more
powerful that information becomes I
think that's amazing information doesn't
just want to be free information wants
everyone to be free now sometimes you'll
go on google and you'll ask the question
is there something wrong with me and the
answer comes back yes double years back
I woke up one morning and I could not
feel the whole right side of my face
completely you know numb and floppy and
I couldn't do anything with it you can
imagine the questions that are going
through my head you know what am I am i
dying am I having a stroke is this what
the hell is this was i drinking anything
last night that might have caused this
so I got my laptop and you know I
googled the symptoms I went to Google I
thought why can't I feel my face and I
clicked search and I got can't feel my
face by the weekend
a singer from Canada and I thought and
context you know questions are hard so I
tried Google foo I thought okay maybe
why can't I move my face and click
through a couple of links and there it
was I had this Bell's palsy which is a
thing that affects the nerves and gives
you sort of temporary paralysis in one
side of your face and total time from
you know panic to having my question
answered was maybe two or three minutes
so I emailed work I said you know I
gonna the doctor get this thing checked
out went to the doctor they said it's
fine it'll go away by itself I went I
got a cup of coffee and I spilled it all
down my side because I forgot that my
face wasn't working so I've got a straw
and I'm sat there you know whether with
a straw and a cup of coffee and I'm
thinking you know on the one hand this
is amazing you know I can I can wake up
figure there's something wrong with me
grab my laptop and get a diagnosis in
you know a couple of minutes but then
it's so clunky having to describe what
happens between neurological disorder
and Canadian hit singer is the
difference between move and feel you
know this is a really inelegant
mechanism for doing this kind of stuff
but we're approaching an age when you
know monitoring health and livelihood
and fitness is just going to get more
and more advanced as anyone here got a
Fitbit raise your hand okay now put your
hand down you raise your hand again lay
on down again you do that 10 times the
internet'll think you've had a workout
just you know don't don't skip leg day
Fitbit is just the beginning we can wear
these devices which monitor you know
breathing heart rate blood pressure all
these kinds of things but we're still
restricted because all they can get is
data that is available externally most
people aren't up yet for the idea of
actually having technology permanently
implanted inside their body I say most
people there's quite a lot of people who
have done this because it was better
than the alternative this is me this is
my titanium cyborg Terminator
exoskeleton
thanks to a skiing accident in 2014 now
I never wanted an exoskeleton because
it's actually a pretty cumbersome thing
to have to deal with but I fell over
skiing I broke my leg and they said well
you know we can put pins in it or you
can just use the other leg for the rest
of your life there are circumstances
already you know there are people who
have insulin pumps there are people who
have pacemakers there are already people
for whom having technology implanted in
their body to do these diagnoses is
better than the alternative and we're
starting to see pre-emptive diagnostic
technology you know people whose whose
genetic scan says they're at risk of a
certain disorder they'll actually put a
device in them that will give them early
warning at certain types of cancer liver
disease
far far before any actual symptoms would
manifest you know before they get sick
this little device will ping the
healthcare provider probably using Wi-Fi
I don't know and say you know you should
go and get this thing checked out this
might be a sign of something bad and
it's going to get better you know
imagine this before you're born yeah
there's already you know micro nanobots
circulating in your bloodstream
scanning pH levels insulin levels toxins
when you go to hospital you don't even
have to do tests they already know
what's wrong you know maybe you don't
even know you need to go to hospital
maybe you slip in your bathroom and you
fall and these machines in your
bloodstream go okay sudden acceleration
sudden deceleration rapid loss in blood
pressure
no movement brain activity's gone a bit
weird call the paramedics tell them
exactly where we are where I am tell
them what's wrong with me tell them my
heart is still beating tell them
breathing is very shallow
and by the way send them the code to the
entry phone on the building so they have
to kick the door and when they get here
you know this is this is beyond science
fiction even in Star Trek they still
found people unconscious in the corridor
and beamed them to sickbay so someone
could wave a tricorder over them you
know and this raises even more questions
we had an outbreak in the UK last month
there was a one a crypto ransomware worm
that swept through lots of organizations
including the the NHS and it's this
thing takes over your machine encrypts
all your files and says please pay us a
ransom using Bitcoin and you know the
social media outbreak was like ah why
didn't you patch your machines you
really seriously running Windows XP so
here's a question for you how much does
it
to upgrade a Windows XP machine context
it depends that Windows XP culet packard
laptop that grandma uses to look at baby
pictures
copy the pictures onto a Chromebook and
throw the HP away if you won't notice
but these were not grandma's laptop this
is an XP machine which is the control
system for a 1.5 million pound magnetic
resonance imaging scanner the big
machine on the Left saves people's lives
all day every day the little machine on
the right runs Windows XP if you upgrade
the little machine the big machine will
stop working there is no firmware
upgrade for this the in some cases the
manufacturers are out of business in
some cases the manufacturers just don't
care they have a new machine that they
want you to buy are you going to be the
engineer who upgrades that machine to
Windows 10 because our viruses and then
has to explain that these people who are
waiting for life-saving diagnostic
treatment they can't have it because
you're waiting to buy a new MRI scanner
and then you go to the hospital funding
board and you're like we need a new MRI
scanner and they say well you've got one
on the other yeah we need a new one why
because new one runs Windows 10 and
they're like are you serious you want to
spend 1.5 million pounds just to be able
to run Windows 10 you know there are
really complicated questions around the
relationship between IT and things like
health care you know little computers
talk into these big complicated machines
it gets even more complicated imagine
this you get these weird stabbing pains
down your left side so you got a
hospital and they inject you with
nanobots and they do a diagnosis and
they come out with you know a couple of
gigs of data the most accurate scan of
your body that has ever been performed
who owns it who owns that information at
yours you know it came from your body
but in the UK if someone takes a
photograph of you they own the
photograph you don't copyright lies with
the photographer did the person who
injected the nanobots do they own your
data now does the hospital own your data
what if the hospital has picked a box
that says we'll share diagnostic data
with the nanobot manufacturers to help
them troubleshoot their software and
then the nano bot manufacturer gets
bought by an insurance company who
decide they're going to use that data
for advertising purposes and then one
day you're shopping on Amazon and you
get an ad a
banner ad pop-up that says hey have you
made a will you don't have as much time
as you think you do
Dylan better call Saul these are scary
questions but they are important you
know and there are fields where we as a
species of society already deal with
this we have medical malpractice
insurance you know we have when
airliners crash we have this thing in
agile software and fail fast and cheap
when airliners crash it's very very fast
and it's not even remotely cheap and so
every single incident in the airline
industry the way to recover that cost
you know cost in money in time in human
lives is to learn absolutely everything
we can from every single one of those
failures you know software software
development computers networks have got
us an astonishing distance in a short
space of time but if we're going to
reach a world where we have medical
nanobots and self-driving cars and
machine learning and smart algorithms we
need to be able to inspire and engage
the best parts of those industries as
well we can't do this on our own
technology can be an amazing disrupter
but there is a very very fine line if
we're not asking the right questions
it's all too easy to go from disruption
to destruction and finally today I want
to talk about the biggest question of
all what is the ultimate answer to life
the universe and everything
three-two-one 42 that's not the most
important question the most important
question is why and on the subject of
why I'm going to hand you over to louis
c.k right is my daughter the other day
she's like papa why can't we go outside
well cuz it's raining why well water is
coming out of the sky why because it was
in a cloud why well clouds form when
there's vapor
why I don't know I don't know that's I
don't know any more things those are all
the things I know
why because I'm stupid okay I'm stupid
why well because I didn't pay attention
in school okay I went to school but I
didn't listen in class why this is a
diagnostic technique called the five
why's analysis why did this happen
why why why being software developers is
kind of like having small children you
know database server one failed in the
night why because the discs are full why
because we are writing log files to it
why because I don't know all the people
who knew that left why because you're
not a good boss to work for why you know
you can very rapidly you start asking
why curiosity can drive you to
deconstruct things astonishingly but
we're on the cusp of an error in
Information Systems where we won't be
able to do that anymore YouTube has an
algorithm that will tell you what video
you might like to watch next
nobody knows no human being knows why it
recommended you that video they took a
neural network machine learning system
and they fed you know a couple of
million test cases through it and now it
just does its own thing and we don't
know why you know nobody knows that we
have quoting engines we have systems
built into insurance quoting systems you
get charged twice as much for contents
insurance as your neighbor does you ring
them up you say why they say oh that's
what the computer says you know it's
going to become more and more difficult
for us to get answers to these kinds of
questions we want to know why you know
we're curious why did my self-driving
car decide it was time to drive into a
hedge maybe we'll never know or maybe
that's the biggest single question that
is facing the technology industry today
maybe we need to be able to turn to our
machines to our software and we want to
ask it questions itself why this video
why is the insurance quote so much why
did you drive into a hedge and maybe one
day you know even more sophisticated
questions research returns to their
prototype neural network and they say
who are you but until then we got this
we're human beings were curious and we
are unstoppable we created arithmetic we
created the microprocessor Daisy Allah
on Twitter put this up the other day
if you ever code something that feels
like a hack remember that a CPU is
literally a rock that we tricked into
thinking and the first comment on it was
someone going
don't forget first we flattened the rock
and filled it with lightning you know I
think this is fantastic we've built
rockets that took us to the Stars and
the moon we've built artificial planets
and satellites
we've worked around the fundamental
curvature of space-time we have
algorithms that can index with sum total
of all human knowledge and we're only
just getting started over the next three
days you are going to meet and talk to
some of the most brilliant and creative
people I've ever had the pleasure of
knowing talk to them ask them questions
listen to their questions have a
fantastic time enjoy yourselves
meet some old friends make some new
friends and ladies and gentlemen of the
audience of MVC use flat screens if I
could offer you only one tip for the
future flat screens would be it the
benefits of flat screens have been
proved in Hollywood whereas the rest of
my advice has no basis more reliable
than my own meandering experience I will
dispense this advice
enjoy the confidence and optimism of
greenfield projects oh never mind you'll
not appreciate the confidence and
optimism of Greenfield until things
start going to hell but trust me when
you finally ship you'll look back if the
code you wrote and recall in a way you
can't grasp now how simple everything
seemed and how productive you really
were your code is not as bad as you
imagined don't worry about changing
database providers or worry but know
everyone who ever used an ORM in case
they needed to switch databases never
did it the real problems on your
projects are the dependencies you can't
control the engineer who unexpectedly
leaves your team at 4:00 p.m. on some
idle choose learn one thing every day
that scares you optimize don't reformat
other people's code bases don't put up
with people who reformat yours rebase
don't get obsessed with frameworks
sometimes they help sometimes they hurt
it's the user experience that matters
and the user doesn't care how you create
it remember the retweets you receive to
get the flame paid if you succeed in
doing this tell me how
keep your old hard drives throw away the
old network cards reflect don't feel
guilty if you don't understand that shop
some of the most productive junior
developers I've worked with donor shop
some of the best systems architect I've
know steel things right plenty of tests
be kind to your keys you'll miss them
when they build maybe you have an open
source project maybe you don't maybe
work on Microsoft SharePoint maybe you
wrote code that flow on the Space
Shuttle whatever you do keep improving
don't worry about where your next gig is
coming from there is a big old world out
there and they're always going to need
your developers look after your brain
don't burn out never be scared to take a
break it is the most powerful computer
you will ever own launch even if you
have no users with your own QA team have
a plan even if you choose not to follow
it
do not read the comments on YouTube they
will only make you angry
- your package dependencies you never
know when they might be gone for good
read your log files they're your best
source of information and the first
place you'll notice if something is
starting to go wrong understand the
languages and frameworks will come and
go and it's the underlying patterns
really matter work hard to fill the gaps
in your knowledge because the wider you
get the more you'll regret the things
you didn't know when you were young
develop an x86 assembler once but stop
the fourth makes you smug develop
individual basic ones stop the fourth
makes you stupid
read accept certain inalienable truths
your code has buds you will miss your
deadlines and you too might end up in
management and when you do you'll
fantasize that when you're a developer
code was bug free deadlines were met and
developers tune their database indexes
tune your database indexes don't deploy
your code without testing it maybe you
have a QA team maybe you have
integration tasks you never know when
either one of them might miss something
don't mess too much with your user
interface or by the time you ship it
will look like a carrier be grateful for
open source code be careful whose code
you run writing good code is hard and
there's more to it than taking your
project folder slapping a readme file on
it
and hoping if you share it on github
somebody else will come along and fix
all of your problems
but NDC trust me on the flat screens
thank you
[Applause]